foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the dragon video in this video
I want to have a look at all of HBO's
new official photos from this Sunday's
episode their photos give us another
great look at what will be happening in
episode 8 of House of the Dragon if any
of you do not want to know what happens
in The Following episode I would highly
recommend shutting off this video now
because I will not be holding anything
back I always say exactly what's on my
mind even if it does reveal major events
from the season most of you who are ride
or die with me know that already now
before we start actually looking at
these new official photos I want to let
all of you know about something that I
think you could find as beneficial as I
do I want to discuss the sponsor of this
video Atlas VPN as I'm sure most of you
already know all of us are at risk of
having our identity stolen on a daily
basis as more and more of our
information and data goes onto the
internet what some of you might not know
is that one of the best ways of stopping
this from happening is by the use of a
VPN service I actually use mine every
day in fact I won't turn on any of my
devices unless I'm already connected
well this month I've joined forces with
Atlas VPN to bring you the most
affordable deal on online protection for
as little as 1.99 each month they also
give you a 30 day money back guarantee
now other than guarding your online
identity Atlas VPN also blocks malware
and malicious links they will make sure
your Google searches are private and
they'll give you access to online
shopping deals and even notify you
whenever someone is trying to steal your
identity one of my favorite things about
Atlas VPN is it also gives you access to
other regions content on the different
streaming services like Netflix for
example if something is only available
in the UK all you have to do is switch
your IP address to gain access to it in
the US right now Atlas VPN is running a
massive discount to where you can
actually get a three-year subscription
for only 1.99 each month and don't
forget that also has a 30 day money back
guarantee all of you can jump on that
deal right now before time Runs Out by
going to the link in my description a
recommend grabbing that deal now once
again I would like to thank atlasvpn for
sponsoring the video alright now let's
see what's going to be happening in all
of the different scenes in the new
episode this Sunday in the First new
photo from HBO we see reniro Zelda's son
jacari's valerion once again HBO has
found another new actor to step in as
raniera's firstborn son he should remain
in the show from here on out now if you
look at some of these other photos as
well as the official video HBO released
earlier in the week for the episode I
believe we will see a feast held by
viserys and King's Landing we actually
hear about the feast and George RR
Martin's Novella they may do this a
little differently in the show but
basically what happens is viserys has a
feast to celebrate his recovery he more
or less forces his wife Alison and his
daughter ranera as well as their
children to attend the feast as a way
for them to hopefully fix their severed
relationships in a show of Harmony
rhaenyra was wearing a green dress for
Allison and Allison was wearing a black
dress for rhaenyra and many declaration
nations of Love were made during the
feast Damon raised a glass for Serato
and thanked him for his service as
saying to the king and Serato even
showed some love to Damon as well
meanwhile Allison and runner's children
greeted each other and broke bread
together at the table or so the records
say however later that evening after
viserys had left mushroom says aemon one
eye lifted his drink in the air for his
Valyrian cousins he spoke in a mock
admiration of their brown hair brown
eyes and their strength aemon said I
have never known anyone so strong as my
sweet cousins he ended so let us drain
our cups to these three strong boys
still later mushroom says aegon was
anchored when jacaris asked his wife
Elena for a dance that's right aegon
eventually does marry his own sister
Helena angry words were then thrown at
each other and the boys might have
fought each other if not for the
intervention of the kingsguard whether
viserys was ever informed of these
incidents we do not know but rhaenira
and her sons went back to their own seat
on Dragonstone the next morning now
although this fight was avoided in
George R Martin's Novella it doesn't
look like that will happen in the show
we've already seen aegon and lucari's
fighting as well as aemon and jacaris as
you can see HBO has released a bunch of
new photos from this scene we see Amon
addressing raniera's Sons right before
their fight we also see aegon sitting
here having his dinner and there's also
a handful of photos of Allison and her
father Serato at the feast it should be
very fun watching everyone as they act
like they're friends with the other side
we all know these relationships are over
rhaenyra Allison and their sons will
never get along with each other ever
again especially not after aemon lost
his eye and Allison lost her damn mind
after she ran at renera in her sons
while she had the Valyrian steel dagger
in her hand these new photos show us
another very interesting scene that will
be happening within the red keep of
King's Landing if he saw HBO's video
then you already know we will see
Serrato Tower sitting on the Iron Throne
we also know rhaenyra and her sons will
be here as well in HBO's new photos you
can see rainey's will also be here and I
find this very interesting because of
how she is standing if you look at
rainey's in the photo it looks as if
she's addressing Serato not only is she
standing off to the side but everyone
seems to be looking at her Damon his
daughter and ranera are definitely
looking her way and rhaenys does not
look very happy in fact I would say she
looks kind of sad or as if something bad
might be happening now if you look at
this other new photo from HBO you can
see vamon valerion is here as well I
also find this very interesting because
of what we heard in HBO's official video
for the upcoming episode we hear how the
sea snake has suffered a grave injury
during his fighting in the stepstones
then we see vamon on driftmark asking
rhaenys about The Driftwood Throne if
you saw one of my last videos then you
know I think vamon will make a move to
get the Driftwood throne for himself not
only is the sea snake grave injured but
his heirs to drift Mark are now dead as
well lady Lena valerion is dead and as
we all know Lenor valerion faked his
death that only leaves rhaenyra's Sons
but vamon and everyone else already
knows they're not legitimate errors I
think vemon is there on drift Mark
asking rhaenys to make him the new Heir
and I think this might have something to
do with what's happening in the Great
Hall of the Reiki Daemon is there for
some reason and rhaenys is standing
before the Iron Throne looking all sad
for some reason I do wonder if vemon is
forcing her hand and I also wonder if
vemon and Serato made a deal behind the
scenes we did see Serato is discussing
something with someone in the video and
we see vemon is discussing something
with someone as well I wonder if they're
having a meeting and working something
out together there's a good reason he's
asking rhaenys about The Driftwood
Throne while the sea snake just so
happens to be gone and injured and
there's got to be a good reason why
rhaenys is standing before the Iron
Throne looking like this also if you
remember from a HBO's video we even see
how shocked lucarius looks when vamon
rolls up in King's Landing like he owns
the city I think he's about to make a
major move in this next episode that
will stun everyone let me know what you
think now in the last new photo HBO
released we see Damon holding the dragon
egg again now that him and ranera have
been married for a few years I believe
they've already had their first son and
like I said in one of my last videos I
think he's giving the egg to their
newborn son either that or maybe Damon
is up to something sneaky as well we do
know he will be reuniting with his
former lover massaria they were shown
meeting up together in the dark hallways
of the red keep maybe Damon will use the
dragon egg as some sort of currency for
something else as you all know dragon
eggs are worth a lot of money he could
use it to get an army or maybe some
other things of high value maybe it's
only me but I don't think he's looking
for masarya for sex I think he's making
a move of his own but we shall see once
again I think we're about to be in for
one hell of an episode this show is
about to go to a whole new level now
that we're finally on the verge of the
dance of the Dragons I would get ready
my friends because the dragons are about
to make a rain fire over Westeros do any
of you agree with what I said or is
there something I'm missing or
overlooking I want to hear what you have
to say as always I want to thank all of
you for watching my video I hope all of
you have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]